now the boss of Tesco has hit back at
critics who have blamed supermarkets for
high food inflation the bank of England
some politicians and unions have all
accused the grocery sector of
profiteering but Tesco chief executive
Ken Murphy says it's unfair and he
thinks the UK is past the worst of
inflation well let's bring in our
business correspondent gurpreet narwan
um he's fighting back pretty strongly
there go priest yeah supermarkets have
been coming under intense scrutiny over
their pricing policies But Ken Murphy
chief executive of Tesco was eager to
butt away any suggestions that
supermarkets may be to blame for
stubbornly high prices in store it comes
at a time when food price inflation is
running at 20 but commodity prices
that's things like wheat oil and
fertilizer have all been falling in
price over the past year in explaining
this discrepancy Andrew Bailey the
governor of the bank of England said
last month that food producers may be
maintaining their margins or rather
rebuilding their margins instead of
passing on falling commodity prices to
Consumers the bank said that this may
explain why food price inflation has
been slower to fall than it expected
Tesco said it was having almost daily
conversations with its suppliers asking
them to justify their prices for their
own part Tesco said that it was quick to
pass on falling commodity prices to
Consumers but that it was facing other
pressures chiefly High labor costs which
it also has to factor in when setting
prices now there was some good news in
this Tesco said that there were early
and encouraging signs that food price
inflation is easing it said that we had
passed the peak of inflation and that
prices should start moderating this year